[Music]
today i have never been more proud to be
a ukrainian and i've never been more
proud to be married to ukraine
the people of ukraine are strong and
brave but being strong and brave doesn't
mean you're not worthy of support we
need to support the people of ukraine
please help us let's support them with
better than we can
that's ashton and mila all massed up
stepping out in west hollywood just
hours after launching their gofundme for
ukrainian relief their goal 30 million
dollars we need your help
mila was just seven when she moved with
her family to the u.s and she still
speaks fluent russian
[Music]
at this moscow press conference the
actress defended her friends with
benefits co-star justin timberlake when
a russian reporter questioned why he was
focusing on movies and not music
this is my bodyguard
also grappling with the crisis in
ukraine max smirkovsky this is new video
of the ukrainian-born dancer happy to be
home and holding hands with wife peter
murgatroyd on a malibu beach yesterday
i was the only reporter at lax for the
couple's emotional reunion after max
left ukraine welcome home man we're glad
you're safe
this morning max told gma he was
struggling with feelings of guilt i
cried on the way from from the airport i
felt embarrassed
you know i felt embarrassed the entire
ride back because i was the only man on
the train amongst all women and children
max also revealed ukrainian authorities
cut him a break when he was arrested for
breaking curfew there then the guy next
to him goes oh that's the judge from
dancing with the stars that's max i know
him he's from tv i'm like he goes get
inside right now
[Music]